starts with the black pieces and the
name of the game is survival for
Nakamura if Magnus wins this one the
match is over for today goes back to
that tried and trusted recipe Knight F3
opening with the ready opening and he
has he's changed up his openings here I
mean I think he's just got to try and
draw this game
um unless he gets some chances of course
and he's got to get uh that last game
out of his mind because he probably put
it on the computer uh engine afterwards
and or you know you could see his
reaction he was very upset of himself so
he's got to distance himself away from
what happened there and that that drawer
offer Gary Kasparov it can get very
sharp there and he has played it I'm
really happy to see this move it's very
exciting and Magnus playing in the
center so we could get a main line
King's Indian defense and uh I'd always
been interested to see what Magnus has
against the king's Indian defense here
he's going to have we have the main line
this is great to see like it's really
exciting feel your salivating Simon yeah
I am really excited uh so I think we
have to jump in just a quick action
replay of what's happened this is the
current position we left the game around
here black struck out in the center and
Magnus was happy after a nataku and
black queen to Simply uh kind of trade
off in the center the writing move here
would have been stepping forward proper
King's Indian style where black would
attack on the king side white on the
queen side but Magnus remember he's
leading in the match so he takes the
safe option and quintancy one really
sneaky lining up on this diagonal trying
to kick back the Black Knight next move
and this is how we got that structure
Pawn to C5 a sacrifice if the Black
Knight takes this Pawn then white is
doing pretty well after Knight to D5
hitting this pawn and unleashing an
attack against the Black Knight so
instead C6 and a trade and now I think
everything on the king side kind of uh
this half of the board looks pretty
balanced pretty uh kind of level it's
all about the other flank and I'm
looking at these black pawns I'm
thinking those are ugly okay Magnus
first kicks back the Black Knight and
then centralizes his Rook if he can
somehow maneuver one of these two
knights into the beautiful D6 Square
long-term Magnus is simply winning but
it's a Hikaru of course has three or
four moves to fight against that he
starts by hitting this Pawn you pointed
this at 92.94 get that Knight onto that
D6 square a plan that has been stopped
right now by magnus's move 98 and F5 is
on the board this is going to get
chaotic I think you might have to just
take this platform before it continues
advancing
uh but okay there we go a Trader pawns
at least now you've held up uh that kind
of Pawn push temporarily White Queen
being on the same diagonal as the black
king a little awkward pin there for
Hikaru and now another pin Simon this
move rooked E1 it looks like Magnus has
lost a bit of time he's kind of kind of
yo-yoed back and forth with the white
Rook but he's lining up David
before so there are a lot
of largely exist in the position E4 94
suddenly this game getting out of the
way getting out of Dodge Queen F7 looks
very healthy and I think I can get this
risk-free end game and then just let's
Magnus off the
end the games too quickly who don't
fight to the bit around who don't take
uh kind of principled active aggressive
decisions and yeah Nakamura offering a
draw in that last game kind of for
showing them okay I'm the one trying to
win I'm the one trying to win you're
just playing for a draw at the very best
and uh okay we'll see uh kind of history
is of course written by the winners
Hikaru right now it looks like he's in a
bit of trouble on the board I love what
Magnus has been doing he slowly
maneuvered he's taking two moves but
he's brought his Knight around to the
king side ah starting to hint at those
threats as we highlighted as well and
okay the king just drop back I'm
expecting your move on the board Simon
um and he does play it immediately I
think black's only move is to play E4
here uh but it looks it looks kind of
loose right oh okay he's he's just
defended his Pawn in a sensible way but
everything is just hanging on for black
here and if Magnus actually is able to
convert this one that's just match over
for Hikaru that's a collapse of the
match for uh for Hikaru Magnus in
driver's seat right now the bishop has
dropped back to D2 so ideas of rerouting
the bishop to the other diagonal you
want to put it to C3 again Target that
Central E5 Pawn uh trying to get rid of
blacks dark Squad bishop and try to
start an attack but you can never do
this because the G6 square is just too
weak so on the board oh really is he
giving up the queen what's happened here
what is happening here what is
randomizing he's gambling yeah this is
going to land with a check I think this
is almost guaranteed at this point
Magnus will give this check the
difference here is not it's not game
over it's not Checkmate because this
time the king can use the G8 Square
which was uh liberated by the black Rook
last turn and he's just giving up
material here I I like that I kind of
like the idea because he's got to take a
risk but it's hot it's hard to get away
with such a move against Magnus Castle
right I mean uh against me easy but I
mean uh not against Magnus and what does
he play here then kind of controlled
himself he's paused here he's
calculating but that line there we go
Knight to H5 it's very linear it's very
direct and suddenly look at hikaru's
reaction not H5 landed on the board he
looked away and disgust and he now
realized that the bishop to F5 does not
work the move he was relying upon it
looked like a double attack but White's
Queen would just capture an F5 and that
fork all those kind of traits lead to a
winning end game for white and that's
why the bars got so excited Hikaru in
huge trouble yeah I don't think he'll
make it for the next couple of moves in
this one he does fall back with the
bishop so not allowing the trade on G7
does white have time now to actually
just get greedy with that Rook on that
fit Knight f8 is that what you just go
for and ask black to actually show what
compensation you've got Knight takes
Rook looks promising Knight takes Bishop
looks promising this Pawn is collapsing
uh Magnus sport for choice and he does
go for the material he does play G4 wow
because I'm pretty sure he's made of AI
Magnus Carson you said AI artificial
intelligence it's absolutely insane is
the AI that I think of when you think
about flashy move there from Hikaru but
white
Zooms in with the track and I think we
will see the final flourishes on this
game white tonight saves itself white is
up a whole exchange and a pawn and
blacks King side in tatters
continues in the winners bracket might
be something stronger but it looks it
looks horrendous and the Queen instead
this is this is also going to be a
killer blow Magnus and his Queen moves
tell me about a love story yeah she
loves his Queens especially in the
center of the board I don't know how
they always end up on these amazing
squares why it's uh well magnus's Queens
in particular it gives a check Black's
King sidelined and
okay under one minute but of course it's
those Queens again she lines up against
the black king and Hikaru now threatened
with a devastating discover check the
white Bishop hoping to jump out the way
next move and what to do how to defend I
I guess whites yeah and uh Hikaru has
played it he's got to get away from that
check and how does white now finish this
off I mean three pieces attacking
against an exposed King is normally
enough but it feels like you might need
one more okay the Knight is now aiming
for a better square and a rook coming to
G3 where the Knight just came from is
also going to be uh terminal here so uh
hikara doing his best but he's doing his
best in a very bad uh situation he
didn't do that and well it's creaking
now and I'm expecting your maneuver here
there we go Magnus plays it instantly
the white Rook swings up and across is
this the moment where he's gonna have to
go down into the lower bracket he's
holding on a little bit more but oh so
they're getting in each other's way as
well those pieces and uh you know every
white piece is piling over
20 seconds each I mean you can still
blunder you might as well play on yeah
we saw some mouse lips we saw some crazy
turnarounds in the speed Chess
Championship final so Never Say Never
Hikaru doing the right thing and uh
fighting on never resigned too early uh
never offer a draw too early either but
this one he's fighting to the better end
the problem is his Bishop disappears and
now 27 might have six
oh but this check could be a killer
Magnus using geometry here loose pieces
drop off the black queen undefended I
think after one more accurate check here
the black king will be forced to a
square the White Knight can jump out the
way the black queen would have dropped
and that's the one Queen z7 check on the
board and Hikaru Nakamura with the shake
of his head resigns and Magnus Carlson
taking the match in just three games a
dominating performance today and it all
comes down to that game two where Hikaru
did have his shot